people are talking about the you know
the explicit content Fifty Shades and
you know the things but nothing that
Julie Walters hasn't seen back your car
waiting what our personal services
oh yeah exactly
look it was really ahead of its time it
had all this stuff in there the all the
long all the fetishes
oh yeah no old Cynthia it was about
Cynthia Payne the madam and yes she'd
seen it all and most of it wasn't to do
with sex it was to do with sort of
roleplay first time I met her was in a
sort of sheshe restaurant in Soho really
quiet with with Terry Jones you know
from Monty Python he was directing it
and she walked in and there was a few
diners in there already quite first
thing she said she didn't even say hello
she said do you like sex Joanie the one
pens on who its weak no because you can
find a girl who likes sex you've got
gold she sits down she gets out a whole
load of photographs and the first one
and then I mean really I'd never seen
anything like me in my life in the first
one was this man lying on the floor
covered in sort of some sort of dark
matter look what he wore and she said
that's my bank manager what he's nice
covered in Hoover dust it's what he
likes so he would pay to go and see her
to be covered in Hoover dust and that's
what on that and that was how do you
find that out how do you how do you
discover that you get turned on by
Hoover ducts she said to me [__] look
Johnny if you need a cleaner just ring
me up and I said why would well because
I'll get you a slave I have slaves
people come specially to be you know
beaten and do the cleaning so if you
want somebody all you gotta just want to
beat somebody's got all you've got
absence get give them a toothbrush tell
them to clean the kitchen floor and kick
them up the bun in a pair of high heels
1200 afternoon grab the knife is very
sharp I'm just going to kill all the
guests so thank you very much
now what is the man ready there show
yourself do we have you really read the
books yeah
did you enjoy them no they're shy